It's no secret that the language of love isn't always the most direct.
Let's check out some dating lines and find out what they really mean.
Line 1 : "I'd love to stay out, but I have to get up really early tomorrow."
What it means : "Sorry, you just aren't floating my boat."
If it's 2 AM, no problem, but if the night is young and it's the middle of dinner,...
...there's no connection between you and she wants to exit sooner rather than later.
Line 2: "I had such a good time with you."
What it means : "Wow, you're actually fun and different from all the other guys or girls!"
The person is letting you know that he or she really might like you,...
...(without being too serious) and is trying to find out if you possibly feel the same.
Feel free to respond in kind.
Line 3: "Why don't you come over and I'll cook for you?"
What it means: "Ready to get physical?"
Cooking shows readiness for intimacy.
The person is really inviting you into his or her life.
Congratulations! If you're ready explore things further, tonight could be the night!
Line 4: "I'm just not ready for a relationship."
What it means: "I'm just not in love with you."
It's hard, so, don't be fooled - when this person does meet someone who has that romantic spark,...
...he or she will indeed be ready for a relationship.